les manches et aller m'occuper hamaoka
tant ça veut dire merci parce qu'on va
faire ça c'est du chocolat préféré des
escargots
comme il en vain les escargots avant
qu'on est dans la région j'ai un petit
problème il y ce choeur praliné l'est de
marquer un but marqué l'ex autour c'est
du chocolat noir à l'éval c'est vrai que
c'est alors j'ai vu que c'était déjà du
coq quand tu sens que tu commences
itunes quand tu commences à kiffer le
chocolat noir les lieux et le
pourcentage de kaka dans les yeux qui
piquent le chocolat noir
j'aimerais bien qu'on trouve le plus aux
doigts société voilà des justes à virer
ce stade-ci il aime le chocolat c'est
moi je kiffe le chocolat en regardant
les étoiles
est-ce que tu as le chocolat voir mais
tu puisses au chocolat noir non en fait
à tous voilà pourquoi j'aime pas rien
n'a pas le choix la mort vient à deux
chaussées glacées lalala l'exception qui
confirme la règle mais bien des jaloux
tu n es 2 est ce que ta ble chocolat
mois accès on s'attache au paiement des
salaires cette année allemand
[Rires]
[Musique]
les spectateurs et aux un pack rameurs
ya des bruits qui courent comme moi je
vais arrêter les dégradés progressif
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont demandé parce que le guerrier
arrêter les dégradés progressiste ou pas
voilà on a parlé
alors je vous dis est ce qu un crève
coeur pour moi la réponse est d'accord
la réponse est oui mais tu craches
passion mais ça m'a apporté énormément
de bonheur a été pas mal la veille avec
des peu court était papa lé là j'arrête
points sont les dégâts les progressistes
là je vais faire un dix à jeudi
et là je vais tout voir je vais tout on
fume et je vois tout anxieux mais tu
connaissais toutankhamon qualité de
chevaux une qualité de cheveux comme ça
vous pouvez chercher parmi tous les
animateurs en europe n'a pas alors je me
fais genre il avait mon cul à louhans
cei ok ok à ces renvois
allô allô laurence oui ajouté homassel
rédacteur en chef de thé tnt ça va bien
désolé de t'embêter
j'ai un toit l'a rapidement puisque je
sais pas si tu as vu mais bon il ya un
débat en ce moment c'est le genre du
passeport vaccinale et on a dû un petit
peu la réaction sur ses news
et pour ce sens pour l'émission moi je
voulais simplement savoir ce qu'il avait
vu mon cul avec ses meilleurs cette
année c'est le meilleur tu mérites ta
place
c'est bien sûr le dans le panthéon est
bon à prendre un deuxième trio ça serait
pas mal que nordine le fasse à son café
tous ces panneaux on voit comment tu
devras frank west montant ouais dix mois
moi je t'appelle par rapport à
l'émission de ce soir sais pas si tu as
eu à la times conducteur ou pas encore
non pas encore parce que voilà on a on
voudrait faire venir un invité mais il
semble que toi tu l'as déjà vu ouais tu
l'as vu par rapport aux par rapport au
dossier et tu sais on va faire un truc
sur le sur la vaccination
puis c'est le dossier le passeport
vaccinale il paraît que tu l'as vu
clairement g
c'est le dossier un normand tu vas
recevoir le conducteur et ya bien le
passeport vaccinale
tu sais avec avec sim est la réaction du
monde eto'o et on voulait la voir et
elle ne paraît toi tu sers et m'a dit tu
l'avais vu par rapport au dossier van
finales sur l'ocré
il nous dit que toi tu ne l'a vu quoi
que c'est bon c'est ya pas de souci donc
tu l'as vu ou pas on va mon cul
[Musique]